hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my newsletter readers tawa
who is a Zimbabwe entrepreneur who just
took on the agreement to take and
represent intuit quickbooks software in
Zimbabwe and is trying to sell it there
he's fine and he goes up against big
competitors like pastel that he
mentioned and his wonder how can he
break in and convince people to buy his
soft for everybody everybody over
everybody else's so I've had some
background in software with the biotech
software company that was my first kind
of main venture and what really helped
us is you have to find out what's
different about your software compared
to everybody else's so for us we were a
small start-up you know we didn't really
know what we were doing at the beginning
we had to go up against huge publicly
funded companies and what what we
figured out was our software was the
easiest one to use of anybody out there
so you have to find out how are you
different so for us we didn't have all
the features that everybody else had
especially our big competitors but ours
was the easiest to use and so for our
customers who wanted something that was
easy that did most of the stuff they
need it they could do it through our
software and that was a pitch that
people could quickly understand so we
didn't always win the pictures compared
to our competition if we went
head-to-head but they understood that
you know how we can stand on how we can
help and we did win a lot of business so
for you what's the main difference
between quickbooks and pastel that main
competitor that you're going up against
is it ease of use is it something else
you know figure out some key points that
make you different and just hit those
home emphasize them as much as possible
so people can at least understand and
know how you're different and hopefully
how you're better another thing that
might be useful i don't know how the
culture is in zimbabwe but in North
America here I've never heard of pastel
so I don't know what you know who makes
it or you know how good it is but
QuickBooks is the leader is one of the
leaders for sure in the accounting
software here in North America for
entrepreneurs everybody knows who
quickbooks is as well as simply
accounting they're kind of the two main
software packages that most people use
I've never heard of pastel so it wanted
the messages
be going after saying we'll look at what
they're doing in North America if people
in Zimbabwe look up to North American
businesses is you know kind of the
center of entrepreneurship if people
think that way then dr. be an
opportunity say hey you could be like
these North American companies and and
grow really quickly and you know explode
your business so use the same software
that they use if people in Zimbabwe
don't like North American companies and
I wouldn't use that pitch but quite
often that could be a great way to be
able to present yourself and position
yourself against a bigger competitor who
you know doesn't exist outside of you
know whatever the local market you're in
so I hope that helps for anybody else's
who's how to experience selling software
it'd be great to hear what you have to
say one final thing that I found that
that you know could be really helpful
for you is fine channel partners so for
County software you might want to think
about accountants or bookkeepers all
right as a business owner a lot of
people use accounts a lot of people use
bookkeepers and they don't care you know
who when whatever software they use if
they're bookkeeper or accountant is
using something that's often how to get
the recommendation so try to get in with
the bookkeepers and accountants and
potentially QuickBooks can help refer
you to some people who are in your local
market who are using your software and
get them to be able to recommend you and
refer you to their customers and say you
know we use QuickBooks it's fantastic
you guys should too and as an
entrepreneur when they're starting up or
they're growing your business you listen
to your advice from your bookkeeper your
accountant if they're using certain
software and they recommend you use it
you're probably going to use it so that
could be a good channel for you to be
able to get in as well I hope that helps
if you guys liked the video please give
it a thumbs up it always makes me want
to make more these videos for you guys
and if you have any thoughts I'd love to
hear what you have to think if you leave
a comment of the video you know whatever
I said if you want to comment on it or
if you have another question and leave
it in those comments and thank you and
we'll see you on the next episode
you